dude we used to play a game called
knockout do you guys remember knockout
basketball game yeah yeah and when I was
in high school I was a counselor for
these kids like at a science camp or
whatever and they told me they don't
allow Knockouts like do you guys play
knockout though no we can't because the
ball might hit the hoop and hit somebody
in the head and they're like nah because
people might hit the hoop you guys are
all [ __ ]
[Laughter]
fragile ass [ __ ] is bad
[Music]
do you guys know what this place is
it's in Vietnam so I'm trying oh yeah
it's the [ __ ] train that goes all the
way in that little alley and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I think it's a Hanoi or something yeah
because I've never been to Hanoi so it's
called train Street and uh this is in
Hanoi Vietnam
it's all close you're like this [ __ ]
close it's super popular for having like
the train go uh like centimeters away
from uh the buildings and the people so
then the people that lived along that
track started opening up cafes and stuff
and it's a huge tourist attraction yeah
people so just made it more dangerous
closely hit by train exactly and people
do get hit uh especially tourists
because they stupid yeah and it's it's
uh certain times they had like closed it
off to tourists because they just kept
[ __ ] up and like taking dumb photos
on their tracks uh but now it is for
real for real shut down oh oh no because
too many people
uh yeah
it's it and it's just it not only that
but like a few years ago they did shut
it down because of how dangerous it was
getting but the difference with now is
that they have revoked all of the Cafe's
licenses along the area so now there's
no reason to be there that even the
locals can't have businesses next to
anymore which sucks but do people just
go to look at it because that was what
the whole attraction was you can go to
look at it but uh you know what people
really loved doing was these like rail
side oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] it Railside cafes like that was
like the cool cool thing that's tight
you got a whole you get to eat some fall
when the Train's going
like two inches away from your face
you're like oh my God
no nose
yeah and it was like super popular
because I don't think there's a lot of
places that you can really do that and
uh only in Asia dude yeah and culture
wise it's it's cool enough just to watch
the locals in that area because they'll
be doing [ __ ] on the tracks and
everything and when they know the
train's coming without even like really
thinking they just move and then they're
just back to what they're doing because
they're so used to it that's their daily
life like damn so it was so close you
had to like back up a little bit to even
continue washing your clothes or
something yeah if you didn't make it
into your house you had to hug the wall
like this and the train which goes and
it was just like mad normal to them but
because and it got so popular and
touristy that we just shut it down well
what happened is like it was popular and
then pandemic happened and there were no
tourists so the cafe is kind of closed a
little bit because there was no one
going there and then once travel opened
up again there was just such a huge
influx of just idiots that's true
because those videos those videos came
out during lockdown it went viral during
lockdown so I think people are like yeah
when the [ __ ] borders open I'm so
gonna travel and find myself yeah I
wanted Vietnam to get railed yeah
that's very good I I respect that
but this the sucky thing is that uh for
the locals and the people that own those
coffee shops they were given days notice
so like that was just gonna shut down or
that they had to move out or something
well they just can't be a cafe anymore
like imagine that like that's the part
of Communism that makes me sad that's
the part yeah that's the part where they
could just be like hey no more yeah
you're like really but but I need to
make money no no no we were like a
democracy they basically did that to us
over here
they did you're right you're right well
businesses they all like that oh yeah
that's true gyms their Studios no no
you're last yeah yeah oh you know you're
not social social distancing no more
yeah but at least you could go to
Florida and start a king just Studio
during the pandemic and they would have
been like it's okay Woulda Shoulda
Coulda
talking [ __ ] to myself damn it so that's
um so they put barricades around it so
now you if you go there you just keep
can't even uh it looked like on video
you couldn't even stand at the barricade
and take a photo of the track like
because there's there's guards there at
all times and they're just like how many
people died like a year I don't know how
people died
it does happen that people get hit and
after they had closed it a guy got in
there anyway and got hit that's probably
why they shut it down you know stupid
ass [ __ ] some people deserve to
get hit though you know I think so but I
do feel like people outside of America
are just much more smarter when it comes
to like dangerous [ __ ] because they just
grew up with it because when I was in
Vietnam I'm like how do people [ __ ]
drive and walk jaywalk like this this is
nuts and then after being there I was
like ah I get it like there's a flow
like there's a thing that we just don't
understand as tourists it's Awad you
gotta listen to the [ __ ] world yeah
but there's like a flow of everybody
moving and it's like not dangerous
because everyone's on the same page
um because it becomes normal yeah and I
think living in the United States
everyone's got lawyers everyone doesn't
want to get sued and then there's not if
it's not this problem it's another I
think we hear so many problems in the
news that everything makes us like yeah
like the parks they're getting less and
less fun because the cities keep getting
sued or like there's just all this fun
[ __ ] that keeps taking get taken away
remember when you think back to like the
playgrounds and how they look when you
were a kid when there was sand in them
and [ __ ] and they had those weird rocket
ship things that you could climb up that
were like 50 feet tall or the metal
monkey bars that would burn when it was
the summer here dude we used to play a
game called knockout do you guys
remember knockout basketball game yeah
yeah and when I was in high school I was
a counselor for these kids like at a
science camp or whatever and they told
me they don't allow Knockouts like do
you guys play Knockouts no we can't
because the ball might hit the hoop and
hit somebody in the head and they're
like nah because the ball might hit the
hoop you guys are all [ __ ]
[Laughter]
fragile ass [ __ ] is that
just like stand with the ball and
everyone just looks at it I can
understand them rephrasing the name
knockout maybe seems a little conducive
nah that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] too
it's called compromise bar ah [ __ ] that
like keep the game but change The
Branding yeah I don't know just like
rainbow balance or something like
rainbow battle guarantee the game stays
in oh my God yeah so they took knockout
up man can't play tag tag on Jungle no
no rainbow No Tag I think I don't know
if it's specific to like the jungle gym
area but I've seen things where they're
like no tag is allowed which is like
dude tag is the ultimate Primal kid yeah
running away from it's built in yeah
it's like that's what we like when you
see kittens play and they're like biting
each other's necks like they're
practicing a fight like our tag is
running away from a line like that's
just human it's in the DNA it's in the
DNA yeah when we went through the
playground in uh Australia their jungle
gyms are like way bigger and taller and
it's just like if you they live in the
jungle if you have common sense then you
won't [ __ ] fall in your face you dumb
[ __ ] but then over here man it's just
because if you fall get hurt you're
suing the city yeah that's the thing you
shouldn't be able to sue the city
there's way too many yeah so lawyers
find a way to sue everybody so I have a
friend who works she was doing a
paralegal for the city of La and the
amount of [ __ ] that comes in for the
dumbest stuff that people are suing the
city for she is like you're an idiot if
you don't sue the city really what
should I sue for anything she I mean
this is [ __ ] this is not good advice
because don't actually do this but she
told you yeah she's telling me this is
not legal advice this is my Insider info
from someone who's processing this
paperwork yeah the amount of times
people slip or say they slipped on a
crack on a raised sidewalk which is tons
which is tons and she says every time
the city will pay off how much do you
make why can't you make an income you
could be like I slipped and fell and now
I need two million dollars it depends on
what what the injury is dude I Stumble
all the time and emotionally I'm very
embarrassed how much can I become oh
emotions there's 40 hot girls around
during that day and I [ __ ] shot
myself right after I fell off a lime
scooter what a lot of what a lot of
people are doing and and the city has no
way of like [ __ ] proving you wrong in
this let's say you [ __ ] tore your ACL
doing some other [ __ ] yeah so you should
find the nearest crack on the sidewalk
that's raised and you just take a spill
make sure there's no cameras yeah right
but make sure you take a photo of
yourself oh for the gram how legally is
the city liable for that like I would I
really want to know how does a judge not
go dude you are a [ __ ] I think that it
doesn't even it might not even get to a
judge oil it might just get into like a
quick settlement settlement slush fund
type thing a taxpayer dollars you know
it doesn't dude there are so many
citizens that are just robbing the city
in this exact way and it just quietly
fun
did your friend tell you like minimum
amounts there's probably like an amount
where they're like if if they're suing
for under like let's say fifty thousand
dollars just give it to them but if it's
over that then they have to challenge it
or or throw it out or whatever all I all
I know is that she's she rarely she'll
do like tons of processing per day she's
very rarely just very rarely see
something not get paid I wonder if the
same [ __ ] keeps doing it every month
you should tell you like what's the top
dollar like I'm like that's you know she
just knows the top clients the same
people that go to every corner of the
[ __ ] City and trip all the time but
also you can do property damage where if
you were driving your car and you hit a
pothole like they're never gonna fix a
pothole that someone doesn't Sue over if
that makes sense that's the only reason
to fix it right so if somebody's
constantly suing or there's people
constantly suing over the same pothole
that they keep driving over and their
[ __ ] alignment goes off then they're
gonna go okay it's time to fix a pothole
we've paid out this many people but if
it never happens they never Fix It
Better Call Saul did crack a rim over a
pothole see that's that's the time that
like because I didn't know I could sue
because we don't [ __ ] try to milk the
government exactly we're just not those
types of people but if you're willing to
go through the trouble and the [ __ ]
calls and the paperwork once it gets to
her desk it's just a check mark dude
it's a [ __ ] bro that's insane dude
sue your city
[Music]
thank you